انا من عمان لواء فايزه دويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي لوفائزه اهلا بك
ونبدا بالتطورات المدينه خاصه بالنمط الذي
تحافظ عليه اوكرانيا باستهداف العمق
الروسي اهميه ذلك بغض النظر عن مجريات
المعركه داخل اوكرانيا نفسها
في ظل تعثر الهجوم المضاد كان لابد من
ايجاد مسار موازي لادام اله الحرب ولادام
لادامه الاوضاع مشتعله وبالتالي كان
الخيار المتاح والاسفل
والذي يقع ضمن دائره الامكانات هو استخدام
الصواريخ والطائرات المسيره سواء في شبه
جزيره القرم او في داخل العمق الروسي لان
هذه الوسيله غير مكلفه ماديا
وحتى وان تم اسقاط 90% من هذه الطائرات
تصل طائره واحده او صاروخ واحد يصيب قاعده
مقر للقياده الاسطول في سفر ستوبل يفضي
الى نتائج وبالتالي انه هذا هو الخيار
المتاح لدى الجانب الاوكراني قليل
التكاليف قد يسبب ازعاجات في البعد
السياسي في البعد الاجتماعي وحتى في البعد
المادي اذا هذه الورقه الرابعه الى حد ما
باليد الاوكرانيه
هذا الصراع موجود ورقه رابحه بمعنى ماذا
لواء فايز ما الذي تحققه هذه الضربات
يعني الان اذا عدنا الى يوم الجمعه الماضي
الضربه كانت من سته صواريخ ظل العاصفه
اسقط خمسه استطاع صاروخ ان يصيب الهدف
تحدثت اوكرانيا في البدايه عن قتل قاتل
الاسطول ثم تبين لاحقا انه لم يقتل
وبالتالي يمكن ان تصيب مستودعات ذخيره
تصيب
سفينه انزال كما حدث جسر كيرش وحتى في
وصول طائره الى منطقه ابراج موسكو يتم
اغلاق اربع مطارات في المنطقه اذا هي تسبب
نوع من الارباك في الحياه العامه وقد تلحق
خسائر ولكن لا يوجد انتاج مادي حقيقي فعلي
يؤثر في مجال الحرب
بالذهاب الى ميدان المعركه الرئيسيه في
اوكرانيا نفسها لدينا بعدان بعد الهجوم
المضاده المتعثر كما وصفته ولدينا البعد
الاخر المتعلق ايضا بعوده
فاجنر الى الواجهه الان بهذا الاجتماع مع
اندريه تروشيف ليقوم
بمهام قتاليه ويراس مجموعات قتاليه تتبع
فاجنر نبدا بالبعد الاول ومبررات بنظرك
تعثر هذا الهجوم المضاد
المبررات متعدده الان
اتيح لروسيا وقت طويل من الاعداد والتحضير
وتم بناء خطه دفاعيه في بعض المناطق ثلاثه
خطوط دفاعيه
المتوسط عمق كل خط خمسه كيلو متر بمسافه
بينيه عشرين كيلو متر يبدا بحقول الغام
يبدا بالمضارع الاسمنتيه اسنان التنين
خنادق ضد الدبابات مواقع دفاعيه وبالتالي
تعثرت القوات الاوكرانيه وواجهت صعوبه
كبيره خاصه باجاده روسيا استخدام اسلحه ضد
الدبابات سواء كانت ارض ارض او كانت من
الجو وهذه كانت احد الاسباب الرئيسيه في
تعثر هذا الهجوم وبقائه يقاتل ضمن اطار
الخط الدفاعي الاول الان البعض الاخر
المتعلق بيفاجنر هل نحن بصدد ان روسيا
اي قناه انها لا تستطيع التخلي عن هذه
المجموعه
يعني الان الحديث مختلف عن باقنر القديمه
الان هي كتائم متطوعين مقابل عقود اشار
لها التقرير لكن الامر الملفت للانتباه
الرقم هناك 350 الف في اكثر التقارير
تفاؤلا حول اعداد فاجنر القديمه في ايام
وصلت الى 72 الف فيما التقارير العامه
تحدثت عن 50 الف قتل منهم عشرين الف في
منطقه فاخمد الان نتحدث عن 350 الف هذا
يعني قبل ان نتحدث عن القدره او عدم
القدره نتحدث ان هناك اصرارا روسيا على
الاستمرار في تنفيذ العمليه الخاصه حتى
تحقق اهدافها لا احد يتزاملت دعوتين دعوه
مجندين في في شهر تشرين الاول 130 الف
وسبقها في شهر ثلاثه 147 الف اي بمعنى اخر
277 الف و350 الف متطوع والجيش الروسي
مليون ومئه وخمسين الف هذا يعني ان روسيا
مصره على الاستمرار في هذه المعركه حتى
تحقق اهدافكما ليس بضروره انهم يكونوا
جميعا ضمن فهم متطوعون تحت امرات وزاره
الدفاع شكرا جزيلا لك من عمان لواء فايزه
دويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي